the wonders of the future the marvels of
the presence
science fiction and science innovation
have been intertwined since sci-fi's
origins from video chat to self-driving
cars to space flight
there's the science fiction
and the science reality
sci-fi popped up in the 19th century
during the industrial revolution
when feats of engineering were being
achieved and widely used at lightning
speed all these are part of a modern age
of machines powered by the electricity
by taking existing technology a few
steps beyond reality
science fiction has predicted and
inspired real science innovation
[Music]
how did frankenstein inspire the
pacemaker
let's go back to the late 1700s
when electricity was a subject of
fascination and scientists were testing
its effects on human bodies
luigi galvani discovered in the 1780s
that electric current caused a dead
frog's leg to twitch
in 1803 galvani's nephew giovanni aldini
conducted experiments on the corpses of
criminals in which a jolt of electricity
to the head seemed to cause the body to
reanimate
[Music]
mary shelley heard about these
experiments through her circle of writer
and scientist friends influencing her
novel frankenstein about a scientist
obsessed with the secret of life
dr victor frankenstein assembles body
parts and uses a jolt of electricity to
bring them to life
creating a monster
frankenstein published in 1818 and has
considered both gothic horror and early
science fiction
the movie version starring boris karloff
premiered in 1931 and it inspired a
young earl bakken to work with both
electricity and medicine
[Music]
in 1957 bakken developed the first
wearable battery-powered cardiac
pacemaker
a device that uses electric pulses to
correct abnormal heartbeats
if this sci-fi monster can lead to a
life-saving medical device what else is
sci-fi inspired here's how another
sci-fi story helped pave the way for the
moon landing
in french sci-fi pioneer jules verne's
1865 novel from the earth to the moon
members of a gun club launched
themselves in a projectile from a cannon
to the moon because
why not
[Music]
vern attempted to do the actual math and
work out what it would take to launch a
vehicle to the moon
as it turned out he was surprisingly
accurate
with striking similarities to nasa's
apollo 11 command module
vern's fictional shell was hollow and
made mostly of aluminum
and was crewed by three people
it launched from florida and splashed
down in the pacific ocean like the
apollo 11 command module would just over
100 years later in july 1969
after vern's novel came h.g wells who
wrote the first men in the moon at the
turn of the century
and french filmmaker georges melies
whose 1902 silent film a trip to the
moon is often called the first sci-fi
film
these stories inspired real-life rocket
scientists to continue working on the
problems of space travel
by the 1950s the us and the soviet union
were in a space race the soviet union is
launching the first earth satellite
sputnik 1 flashes its radio signals from
space
three months after sputnik the us
launched explorer one the first american
space satellite
[Music]
off into space man that takes real
teamwork and here's a team of junior
spacemen with an out of this world
breakfast
with the development of space flight
public interest in space science reached
new heights by the 1960s
inspiring future engineers and sci-fi
creators alike
[Music]
and space appeared everywhere in pop
culture
in fashion fashions for the 21st century
home design
toys i'm going to the moon tonight we
got our buster brown risk
even in our cereal bowls new post count
off a new way to help keep you in shape
for the space age
vern's sci-fi mission inspired science
to reach for the moon
back on earth sci-fi turned the
telephone into a radical new way to
connect
as communication devices have
dramatically changed
sci-fi has been a step ahead imagining
new devices and their effects on society
for better
and for worse hey
quit stalling get back to work
mobile phones and tablets appeared in
sci-fi years before we had them in real
life
but what we've wanted all along is
face-to-face contact
[Music]
through a device telephone tv
with callers able to see as well as here
[Music]
at least since the invention of the
telephone illustrators and authors
envisioned combining pictures with sound
like french author and illustrator
george dumarier's telephonoscope which
looks like a combination video phone and
flat screen tv
the video phone appeared in the first
episode of the jetsons in 1962.
when jane jetson had a chat with her
mother
various versions of video chatting
appeared in sci-fi tv and movies during
the 20th century yes what is it
meanwhile att's bell labs was developing
a real life picture phone
[Music]
in april 1964 the picture phone debuted
for public demonstration at the world's
fair in new york two months later
service began with booths in chicago new
york and washington dc
[Music]
first lady of the u.s lady bird johnson
made an early picture phone call to dr
elizabeth wood of bell labs
may i congratulate you and all who have
helped make this great scientific stride
possible
the system was impractical for home use
involving expensive equipment and a
hefty fee per minute
i'm sure that there'll be many
youngsters off the college and many
mothers and fathers back at home that
will find this a great joy
video chatting remained elusive for
three more decades until we had the
internet computers with cameras and the
software to make it work
i bet your next best customers are
grandmothers
skype software was introduced in 2003
and apple's facetime followed in 2010.
we finally achieved the dream of the
video phone
now call your grandma she'd love to see
you
scifi cartoons didn't just predict new
devices they've even influenced modern
housekeeping
sci-fi has long imagined a future with
robots but has often portrayed them as
one-dimensional fully good
or fully evil
early sci-fi robots sometimes tried to
destroy humanity but often they were
helpful assistants doing menial chores
for humans carpet's a bit dirty leave it
to robert he's the perfect household
help all right
like rosie the jetsons family's
housekeeper who cooked cleaned and
helped the kids with homework
most homes today don't yet have robot
butlers but in 2002 robotics company
irobot introduced the roomba a robotic
vacuum that could automatically clean
floors
colin engel co-founder of irobot cites
rosie the robot as an inspiration for
the roomba
thanks rosie
robots that move more like animals or
humans have long been in development
some even exceed human abilities like
that
boston dynamics robots can open doors
carry heavy objects and do
parkour sci-fi has also imagined
artificial intelligence inside machines
that can think and problem solve at a
human-like level
[Music]
one of the first complex sci-fi
portrayals of ai is in 2001 a space
odyssey co-written by arthur c clarke
and director stanley kubrick
marvin minsky an early ai researcher at
mit advised kubrick on the direction of
ai computer hal 9000
hal 9000 could speak good afternoon mr
amer play chess bishop takes knight's
pawn and make plans open the pod bay
doors hell
deadly plans i'm sorry dave
i'm afraid i can't do that
today many of us have a.i in our homes
in the form of assistance alexa and siri
which are friendly
we
hope but as helpful as ai might become
it stops short of processing human
idiosyncrasies and emotion sorry i
didn't quite get that
an issue illustrated in sci-fi by star
trek's android data you told a joke yes
i am not laughing yes
perhaps the joke was not funny no
the joke was funny it's you data
rosie led to the roomba and now we've
got alexa
but where are the cars scifi promised us
sci-fi has long imagined that flying
cars would zip around unencumbered by
traffic where we're going we don't need
roads in star wars blade runner and the
fifth element flying cars just seem
right
coming out of the garage it's an
automobile on its way to a hangar to
become an airplane
while flying cars once seemed inevitable
they haven't quite caught on yet even
though inventors have been trying for
decades
now companies like uber are developing
airborne ride-sharing but the
infrastructure and regulations don't yet
exist to support it
[Music]
sci-fi also predicted self-driving cars
but didn't quite explain how it worked
self-driven self-drive engaged
may i suggest you put the car in the
auto cruise mode for safety sake no you
may not
the self-driving car may soon be a
common reality
google tesla ford uber and others have
been developing self-driving cars for
years
cities including paris and beijing are
testing self-driving cars on the road
and waymo has released a fleet of truly
driverless taxis in phoenix arizona
the cars use sensors and complex
algorithms to navigate and to avoid
collisions
problems have cropped up with some test
projects including crashes a pedestrian
death and even violence towards the cars
which could be typical road rage or the
quirks of interacting with ai
i'm johnny cat where can i take you
tonight which sci-fi also predicted
science fiction creators have not only
envisioned new technologies but have
prototyped the worlds in which they
exist
able to go where science has not yet
gone
the true value of science fiction
to me
threats in the fact that it permits
speculation and makes it respectable
such speculation is important today more
than ever before
tomorrow more than today
the science fiction writer can leap
across chasms where no evidence has yet
filled in matters
as sci-fi's imaginings become reality
they will again inspire real world
innovations which will inspire new
science fiction in a continuing loop
[Music]
you